les professionnels du monde de la
culture était dans la rue aujourd'hui le
but pousser un nouveau cri de ras-le-bol
pour demander la réouverture des lieux
culturels
un an après les premières restrictions
imposées par le gouvernement
a lyon ils étaient plusieurs dizaines à
se rassembler devant la célèbre halle
tony garnier
les manifestants qui regrettent
notamment le mutisme de la ministre de
tutelle roselyne bachelot on l'entend
pas
et nous on nous interdit de jouer elle a
fait de la figuration gouvernement donc
rater pas juste pourquoi elle elle fait
la figure et nous on peut rien faire
donc voila nous on aimerait que les
théâtres ouf comme les supermarchés
parce qu'il ya des meilleures choses
dans les théâtres dans les supermarchés
les mesures sanitaires me tue olabe amie
âgée dans le monde artistique chez
violoniste et c'est ma raison de vivre
et si on enlève ça j'ai pu vraiment
envie de vivre en fait voilà même cri de
désespoir à marseille plusieurs acteurs
du monde de la culture se sont réunis
cet après midi à 14 heures devant
l'hôtel de ville de la cité phocéenne
même image à toulouse où près de 500
personnes se sont réunies devant la
préfecture mise en place pour aider les
intermittents du secteur l'année blanche
dispositif exceptionnel d'indemnisation
doit prendre fin au mois d'août prochain
certains demandent qu'elle soit
prolongée bien sûr nous avons eu l'année
blanche qui permet de
qui a pris en charge les intermittents
jusqu'au mois d'août
mais dans la mesure où la période
d'impossibilité d'impossibilité de
travail et s'est prolongée donc on
appelle à une prenons une prolongation
de l'année blanche
ça peut être par secteur dans la mesure
où effectivement peut-être que le cinéma
continue à travailler en production mais
en ce qui concerne le spectacle vivant
on est vraiment dans une situation on
court à la catastrophe
ce soir à paris des manifestants sont
entrés dans le théâtre de l'odéon avec
l'intention d'y passer la nuit
ils demandent un rendez vous d'urgence
avec jean castex et roselyne bachelot
même si plusieurs concerts tests sont
organisées aucune date de réouverture
des lieux de culture n'a été annoncé
pour l'instant